a ton of black rappers have endorsed
Trump conspicuously the most famous
white rapper hates Trump and constantly
whs about at Eminem but a bunch of other
rappers Kodak
Black Lil pump GCI Kanye of course Lil
Wayne Ice Cube now Meek
Mill yeah have all endorsed Trump at
some point over the last 8 to 10 years
Trump I think is the first Republican
candidate for any office that any
rappers have publicly endorsed you know
that I like to read political philosophy
cisero Aristotle dooso Cortez Edmond
Burke and of course Mars m a
rzz a brilliant political philosopher
who once observed real recognize real
that's what's going on
here